hello everyone and welcome to
today's webinar titled 'to the limit' m increasing the
efficiency of the
molecular diagnostic laboratory the name is maría
antoineta chávez marketing manager at
out and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational webinar is
presented by the avt and brought to you
by the water
molecular division americas scientific affairs team
before we begin i would like to
remind everyone that the event is
interactive we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like and
at any time during  the
presentation
to do this simply write the
question in the box that says ask and
click the sit down button we will
answer as many questions as
we have time at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click the presentation tab
support at the
top right of the
presentation window or let us know about your
pr  Problem by clicking on the box
located on the far left of the
screen
I would now like to introduce our
presenter today, Dr. José
Eduardo, here is the head of the
molecular biology unit. Another laboratory is
dance in Brazil.
Additionally, Dr. Eduardo
Levy is a biologist.  molecular and researcher
is the tropical medicine institute of
the university of sao paulo for more
information in his biography visit
the go see if tab at the
top of the screen now i leave you
with doctor jose eduardo levy
thank you very much maria for the  introduction
thank you very much for the invitation it is a
great pleasure to be here with you and i am going
to talk a little about our experience
and the first experience of america's
with the line
elaborated by biological routine
and here already the statements of
responsibilities
cannot be forgotten is to apologize for
My for you they can't tempt him to the best
that I can as clear as possible but it
happens product  or clear front to the appropriate
to a Spanish but the season is the
best possible
and well I am there in docks in 42
years I started as the coordinator of
molecular biology and now I have a role
more research and research
development the
research development department and how
on the line in the census in common more
research in others the
normal procedures of scientific research in
brazil and that is why what remained in fact
in my responsibility in public I am
here talking to you no well I am a
biologist as I said it varies and has done
a  master's degree in universities are poly
of which molecular the doctoral in
biology also in the open field
I have been doing my research for a long
time mainly the subject of hpv
since 95 but later also working
with those of emerging doses such
as dengue fever and yellow fever and always the
subject
that  I'm going to present to you today
first what
it makes sense to do a
platform switch to a platform like a  Someone
could be important for a
laboratory like daza, then he went on to
talk about the commitment that we have seen there
in our humans with the test of
our laboratory. Lastly, what will be
the impact if we make the change to the
limit in for us it is also
for doctors and patients
so then the weight first
speaking a bit of age given that it calls
given is actually an acronym for
diagnosis of america which was
called that
when it began to make a laboratory group
in a group that grew a lot in
brazil today it is the fifth largest in the world
Diagnostic company is the largest in
Latin America
We are about 37 different laboratories with
different names in Brazil and we began
an expansion through the middle of
South America. First we have the brand, a
brand in Argentina as well and a brand like
Mike, good Argentina and great, and in
Uruguay  also then you are from
growth by markets and fashion by
South America first not to go and well
we are u  A laboratory that has business
in the private field and that's it, what will they be
saying to you, like in Brazil, 18
units where to be here and
not because people go there and they
can take a sample to do the
tests, not only clinical analysis tests
but also  images and
we also have a business sector that
we support where we support other boys who did not
see their duty their death this brand of
more than 100 hospitals of the profile such as the
laboratory differences within the
hospitals we also have the new
brand for the public sector of the
clients  from the government of the governments
of brazil
but that i am going to speak to you in the
molecular biology laboratory our molecular biology
laboratory
is mainly in our
unit in our we call nt or
personal technical nucleus in san paolo
and there we have one or another laboratory of
molecular biology in one of them is a
little smaller
for samples from berto from brazil that
come  in order to stamp them or river to have
yesterday's molecular biology furnace processed in a
hurry to arrest for the
moratorium open field work all the
time 24 hours a day every day of
the week
we have about 55 collaborators there
more than 40 are technicians of people who
live  with the dead the bacteria
both as you say biologists and
American for septics and other
professionals who do not have the
higher level and there it is and we will be in 2019 an
average of 52 thousand molecular tests per month
are
divided there into stress
this type of test we can  say so
then there I select in which the
tests that we do more than 1,000 per month
the one we do the most are mph tests the
papillomavirus of a value if we do
almost 10 thousand tests per month after
the second it is family then there one
can see  the importance of
sexually transmitted infections
for us and especially the health
of women, but also of
men  It's clear and then we have tests such
as
the determination of the fetal sex that is
done with a sample of maternal blood and
about eight weeks pregnant it can
be done and also genetic
tests but simpler genetic tests
not simpler
because we all have 13 hours of discharge
The build that is called Chinese before
is where the whole part of 10
larger, more complex tests are,
also that are done with sequencing platforms
and here we have time
stamps to stay there that we do tests that
we call low complexity, which is
what  It's either talking to you that it has
more, much more volume, or we don't do much
more, I don't know, there's a mix here
mainly of infection agents,
but also some more genetic tests,
yes, point mutations, from there than
simpler things that we do from there.
Well, then we have  our
laboratory five systems that are
called 2000 that can be seen here on the left
these systems have as the m  modules to
a mode that makes the extraction of the
primary sample and after doing that
role of the system I started in
real time and here is the
text amplification mode that has its
interface or that of the system in the
laboratory the lead the system of the
laboratory
and well this process like 96 your
others 94 ours plus the
negative and positive control in a bump takes
about six or seven hours per bump
and here to the right of the n n
molecular law because there are other trade winds that
only guide us or hematology  it has
is the h also 13 called link in by
molecular and the first one from Latin America
went there
whether it is of age or not
and well it seems to me that the main
evolution of this type of system is the
random word the access of the
samples is random  no one needs to
wait for more than 90 88 samples to
start processing as
the samples arrive, it can be put there on the
platform that they are going to start doing the
continuous processing
so this confers much more
flexibility and also a
faster faster platform has there it
can be placed a first time like 12
times 2 shows 60 and 44 are loaded and
in two hours they already have the first ones
where asked later then to the face of
six  minutes has the next two
next where maintenance
is also much less maintenance that needs to
be done weekly and monthly
and the 2000 needs daily maintenance
and also the nem 2000 has
some reagent repairs that are done
manually by the operator and here  there
are no preparations
all the products arrive you can maintain a
love for time until
all our active enjoyment is spent no
but the system also does not have
the reagents to process the number of
samples you already know that  one has to
process there is an end there and now it
makes the operator need to load more
reagents not to be able to process that
number of  samples
good as we are going to evaluate the performance
of the limit system in our
laboratory we are in fact in
protocols as you say or a
research protocol
we evaluate the tests that are
commercially available today in brazil
which is the viral load of hiv the
viral load of hepatitis of the
hepatitis c virus the videos of participate in
the qualitative data of the
permissible sexually transmitted diseases and of high-risk hpv and
what criteria of employees to carry out
a precision the reproducibility the
sensitivity for this we analyze
panels that pay casting
such to the three colists for  all
[Music]
the evaluation of the correlation of the
method with Bavarian samples of
patients of which the state with the
test were deprived with a
reference test in any case more own
than 2000 of water and then
simultaneously with the limit system
also  to see life the confirmation
and also also to features  more
operational like
response time and time not basically the
time needed to process an
ex number of delays the code is good
we start with the hiv the hiv
and there we receive a panel a panel of
three plasma samples of those types of
hiv the  bc and a circulating recombinant form
that is called a
mixture of a with jeff
and returns in four
concentration levels 1250 20 purchases per
milliliter
we made films
we tested about 180 aliquots in 5 days 36
samples per day 2
and do
n't look here  to the results of the
results in the precision of the analysis
that of the highest concentration which is
that of a thousand copies per per milliliter and that
can be seen here by your team c the
subtype the subtype b that the averages
per median are also very very
similar regardless of the
hiv subtype that was tested and the deviations is
because the most important thing
as the standard there are very small very
small and deviations that are not
very large are accepted  s has clinical implications
but here in the fingers they are all less
than 4%
and key in those of 10 where more than 10
here was added
in the tests with the concentration of
200 copies per milliliter in the
recitals very similar but clear
when lowered  it gets closer to the
limit of detection there is more variability it
is an intrinsic characteristic of
any molecular amplification system
there are more variations when you
have a lower amount of analyst
too
and the coefficient of variation is a bit
higher but still less than
25 point in  the standard deviation that was not
considered acceptable by the manufacturer
even
after the third point he could of 50
cuts per milliliter which is here
also a bit of gave him a bit higher as
well but it is still very acceptable
very comparable regardless of the type
of hiv subtype  that s
during was tested
from the qualitative point of view if one
considers the detection rate
with the lowest reviews  the value of
20 copies per ml has detected all
since the whole c and only one of
the recombinant was lost yesterday there is here
so the general detection rate
came out as 97.7 percent and well it must
be said that the subtype is
frequent throughout South America so  the
most important thing for us the cfi more
fredes of the insult argentina uruguay
paraguay
in brazil we have more of the b and after
the e
and after the form they
also combine purity but in panne something
had the time of forgiveness
and well here you can see the
reproducibility when  one looks at the
controls that the controls that we
give to the controls that we use that
come in the kit, then there is a
stronger control and a weaker one, the
strongest has about one hundred thousand copies
per milliliter and the most of it has about a
thousand  copies per milliliter but they will all
be replicated, yes, they were detected with an
average very close to what is
written on the chest
by the manufacturer as well and he gave
standards  very very low is like
ring points six ring points 9 for the
lowest too but eco-efficient like
3 13%
so the possibility can be very
regular from hell and here we do
for our own preparation
shows since the team is also at
a concentration  known and it
was also the same levels of
viral load detected, which we think is
there, it is there and also very low and
also being as recommended since
they are important in Brazil who
also came out with the issue of
pregnancy also dropped since you can
see the  text rate for both
but we see that the four titles
four samples of the four
samples that we used came out 100
percent and that is clear from a
quantitative methodology but it is used a lot
as confirmatory of HIV infection
no and many  Very well situations
were accepted by the scientific community,
doctors too and if one has a
positive serology and does a vial load  ral
álex is positive for the viral load and there is a
number there, so of the confirmation
of infection as well and for this reason it is
important that they have the charitable point of view
the cup cup of good text over
there and we also do a
more real study of the art world of the  five
samples that justice establishes from
art cups so there we have the
bones in the primary blood tube
appear had occurred processed in the
samples from 2000 and then in no more than
30 days also with a processor less
samples of the system reads
and there we compare the  results are the
two platforms that the norm with the
choice of methods
and understand it to be right shows the
greatest representativeness within the
angles that can be had in the
laboratory so negative samples
but very weak positions
in our very high is also in the
second part  from the research the
correlation
here you can see the 188 samples of
hiv-1 that we did in 2000 and the
limits also and  here the correlation is
overall it was 92% v 15
discordant samples which were mainly
samples that had not detected by the
2000 but turned out to detect in on
line and that is understandable because the
limit has cleared down as well and
also samples one other sample that was
certified  that defect for him in 2000
but not because of the system but the
different quantification due to the
limit issue that in general is very comparable
to the current one the classification in
doubts were different platforms
and it may be that this type of graphics is seen better
and then each has  ball is
a patient out of 288 that
we studied
and here are the recording only the two
that have a viral load that's why it would be
137 there is no negative correlation there and they
came out very cheap it's not a line that
has like 45 degrees no because it's
exactly the freezing of the  viral load, well,
the limit that quantifies
only runs to the limit in
quantification with him in 2000 and here they
do another type of to see  r if there is a
type of fence,
a tendency is said for samples that have
lower viral loads to have a
good greater or lesser discrepancy
compared to samples of
higher viral loads and it is to make intense
that happens in greater medium for samples
that have  loads of the lowest
practices of the lows, which is
also expected by said above,
but the average berries is very low, it is
like point 11, which means that the
samples have a tendency to have
a higher identification point where the world
business 10
by the  limit than power in 2000
and the most important thing is this
type of dances of average variation
also that we present this is the
previous one
is less than the clinical difference that
is authorized is evaluated the
clinician values ​​not then in general of hiv
it is considered that there is  a change wants to
help evolution or a regression of the
viral load when it is greater in word
different samples greater than points 5
that sent  mean the others and based on the fact
that we have much better variability than
better,
therefore it can be assumed that the
result of alinghi is very comparable
in the result of my company a
good contest
followed there for hepatitis c we have
worked with a panel also that I do
three teams to 23
all more frequent in all of
america south america then it is
also to assume western land also with
three levels of concentration and in 25 10
city the premier international we made
as 3 aliquots leave and therefore the
total aware of t5 aliquots in
five  days no 27 samples per day
and here also the average may not
change almost at all according to the
genotypes also and here you can see the
coefficient of variation a little higher
for genotype 3 but all the
standard deviations are very very low as point 3 what
going to give hints that we find here
with genotype 3 a colom one looks for the
lowest viral load of 25
international units have the m  same profile
the average very similar with the 3
genotypes also the coefficient of
several are a little higher so
saying that previously also but
if it is expected
the standard deviation also gauging
less than point 5.4 in this case
general address box then 100  %
all the teachers in the country came out
positive from those applied
also the civility reputation with the
controls as we said they came out very
reproducing from the averages exactly
the load expected by the control like
Spain
and in the days here it is they are very low
as haro points 8.09
the  freezing the freezing study
then is from lalin and in 2000 it was
done with 199 hepatitis samples
only seven samples came out discordant
so the component in general was 96
votes 5% and there the discount of
all four that are here that was not
detected  by the limit but they came out
detectable is going to be very low with him in
2002 that had the highest quantification
by the limit  ite but lower
by three thousand euros that has
a slightly different quantification but it was
detected by the current one we do not exist
so the freezing is quite good
96 points 5 percent and with one look at
having here for various reasons of
cogeneration color shows that  It has in
quantification in its 96 of 3.97
and Bayern is also very similar to
having HIV, but it is much more
distributed and due to all the viral changes,
the highest concentration will last,
here you test changes of the lowest,
as we saw, like HIV
1 last.  viral reloads
the hepatitis virus here we have a panel of
two genotypes only
and making it the most common haedo type
we have in South America after
we don't have much here but the father
had that temple
and three concentration levels 2100 in
10 international units per
milliliter so here we also have 15 you
find each hipólito 90 a total of
90 read levels in 5 days I am 28
samples  ras per day the averages
of that very similar also as a
work for the concentration of two thousand
international units with
low tenths in between 12 3%
only one closed with the with the
concentration of 100 also resulted
a little a little little different
between the  ice genotype but also everything
within the acceptable limit by the
manufacturer also by the
in clinical societies also in the
clinical context also
the overall detection rate came out as
93 percent because there was a replicate
here and only one was not detected and that's why it
came out  very one that also then I wanted
14 were detected all with the
concentration lower than 10
units of international region very very
low for the match and alive
and the controls very very productive
always with very low deviations like
points of 8 points of the 6
the  freezing study
v as current 8 samples will be tested
here is this value is correct and they
came from 94%
a judge who does not know  it detected around 2000
but it was general and not even the 2 dead that it
says it detected but playing a
different quantification
[Music]
a sample that was detected by the imf
but it does not test when going to iraq and it is also
really quantified with different v&v
like 45 dead sorry  discordant there are
for a total of 95 percent of
Córdoba it will be 98 deaths here they are in
relation to the positives as point 99 and
a perfect external correlation in the
bar go very low point 11 for molds
and here it is negative because there is a
trend it can be  be true to the
line of having
slightly lower certifications but it does not change anything the
critical point of view is very very
acceptable the disorder of the new
quantity strips of alice from the pp of lalin
de can that in situation of hepatitis
a hepatitis b and c  hiv
the analytical evaluation
met the specifications
described performances within insects the vast
state observing exceeded the
clinically significant threshold p  For all three
of them in this way, the laboratory can make
the transition smoothly. Value went to the
limit of h. Participant seems to be
still live, it is no longer necessary due to the echo, to
establish a dance. They dance for the
patients who are in follow-up.
to be
done by receiving and then
starting with alice is the
right transition of need the need to
change to give exercise nothing because they are
very very similar this program from the
study which for us is very
important because the majority of
our patients want to go with the  two
true a long time and there we are going to make
the change no then the visual sternum had to be
as it contributed with there is
a change in technology it would be very
expensive having
that is why it is good that they are very expensive and
caves and the 22
and also one or the other  conclusion
[Music]
as 87% of the
quantifiable results of the patients there was a
difference more than 2.5 to see and h and
98.5 the one hundred percent  percent had a
difference less than the pain to be
given that I participated so very
comparable
well
we continue for the test of
sexually transmitted diseases and there
we start with the real country also this
panel has five members of the panel
four members and they are low samples of
two times of detection of  the four
agents who are in the eternity test,
exams, etc.
sorry, etc. who are in a family of hysteria
that, like now, mycoplasma and the fifth
country have the four of us together, we are
going to see each other because it is important to
also do this type of panel so
we have five panels we did  six to the
icon of each 30 reads with three totals in
two days that are shown per day
and how it came out it came out that it is a
charitable territory qualifying tests sorry
and therefore it only turns out to see if it does not have
or does not have but I will do a value of s of
oleander  volpes with that as only gay
mark a frozen marker in the
number of people who are there but
we are worrying from there
with the amount but this is that the
report is that the fai with three role of
cabiria counts in which everything has with
the average of the planet and they give away
with centers or the same when they have
peace of mind but  the other agents
together as well, so I show them
monster that there is no type of
interference or division or loss
of efficiency if you have other agents
together or that it is not totally in
common and the situation of the world of something
can not have two
together
I don't know how to apply they all came out positive
in all cases here as you can
see and the seven were very very similar
always with panel 5 that the
agent had pointed out with all the other three
in need they are very low as you
can see here we are talking  here I do not give
the state of loading because there is no
loading and unloading of the if you have the offending farc
later in the second stage in
the evaluation part of the test in the full
sense  arative with samples from the
monk aldo de página there we have always
compared with the test that is in the
bucket of the laboratory routine
so that they look to be used
in the civil sphere also of water and
to see how we nationals of
mycoplasma genitalium we use where
frank the multiple problems of psg
while that of a company and they
call them mobile
here we work with urine and they show
gender that is like magic and here only
with very environmental pressures because
united urine the private test is not done
private to accommodate me neither for me
couplets  of mist and the collection tube
can be the exit tube itself, in the
collective interest, it calls
them a tube of liquid psychology because it
is very common, of course, it could do so much more
than one test, both the molecular test
but also the psychology test in
the same  same ponytail is not very
convenient for the doctor for a
patient as well and for the
term laboratory and here we work with that  a
month 13 collected from 20 inprema
and there go the freezing and the urine here
is in the bottom part family and
misery and the correlation of ropes very
ecological pressure everything so there
we work with 119 samples
here you can see how they came out
positive in one so  general and against the
comparative test that here is the m
2000 and the discrepancies that are here
that were few and the two negatives
having then the 46 of freezing
positive then 95 percent for
chlamydia 94 percent for necessary in
urine and negative 100  percent for
forms 98 to be born 99 for
university in urine also
for two meters ecological gel
we also have a significant number here and
you can see that a
very good positive correlation for stretchers which was
the lowest came out 95% in all the more than
100  percent freezing between
breath and tc in the
difference test that was displaying there the
comparative test
then sums it up there from  the request
for the test of
sexually transmitted diseases may
and are among the crimes are the was the
overall was very low
- which point 29 the firewall response
the panel member were detected
accurately identified and the
overall performance of the test in
different types  of samples showed
excellent behavior of the center 2
and told you how this is important
for a laboratory like us
that many many many samples
receive many samples from
has like waving many
football votes finally in the fifth test that leads
new from there general  and that it was the
high-risk hpv test
that is an
ebro vida test we can say so because they
have a broader genotypic profile of hpv it
has the 214 types that the
2000 test had but here you have more salt in
the 2000 test it has  vph from 6 mph
and 18 or 2 of other types 2 is called other
high risk here they don't have 45 only
also later they have another one that is  call
other groups
other groups see here the uruguay group
comes has tolls that are high
risk but not as high as 16 or 18
45 and is on the air they allowed
personality management and according to
I chose disc and each type of vph has
for the development of dropping out of school
then it makes more sense here with some
feet this type of test for
the message of neck cancer which is
a trend and some countries in
our region started brazil
not yet but i know ecuador yes as i
said from  argentina also mexico
also so there is a clear test
that you can use as diagnostic tests
but this genotypic profile is very
interesting to do for everything whether it is
landscape policies
and there when one compares the results
with the difference test which is the
least test  1000 we have 200 of 18
samples,
a very high concurrence and I only had
22 samples here that we are going to lower a
little after they came out positive  s
for the element detected as other
agape others of ph is of high risk but
it was not detected by the lalin and that all
the others came out perfectly with
contrasts
and we tried to make a comparison
because we have this is
also the result of the cytology that is very
important  and
the
people who do the
cytology reading that was requested on the TC, the
HPV test has its result
before doing the reading, so they know the
result of the PH to later do a
reading of the  psychology, which has already been
shown to greatly improve the quality
of the cytology if one knows the result
of hpv before starting to see the
pathologies of the mine, although it can be
seen here in the distribution according
to the psychology class, then a
thousand is  the name name for the
normal cytology after in the cytology
of altering the indeterminate meaning
the increasing rhythm of princess from where
when touching all ent  once
is where the gift of high degree is lower
and here is the alteration that
a serious auto method cannot be ruled out
and when one looks here two points the
painted ones that they had that came out
negative by the test at the limit but
positive by him in 2000  they had since
essentially they had
normal cytology we believe
technology practically normal
so there was no negative sample in
the law that had a risk indicated
by cytology of a presence of a
lesion of a class or was engaged between
epithelial
at the same time all the samples  who
had a cytology classified as
altered risk there are 24 samples all
detectable by some type of hpv
the summary is that there was a
total accuracy for vph from 6 mph 18 also and
between lalin and has 3000
a little lower like 95% for  the other
types of hpv all the samples with the
fruit trees where it is altered of
clinical importance were the hpv detected and the
entire sample with results  The
undetected did not create a cytology of
important clinical significance.
Finally, the most personal point of view
in the evaluation of the
response time 1 must be taken into account. We have
the objective of determining the true
laboratory time necessary to
process and help samples when  the
1000 compared to an expert with
the limit compared to the system
in 2000 and of various different
characteristics but evaluated by
time was one that was highly valued
so there we will be a new measurement
of the 10 of the entrance of the laboratory and
there  to do at the end of the process everything
must be kept in mind he
is aware that there are three types three
time points the total response time
that he calls touch is from the
arrival of the laboratory sample
until then and putting the results
our point is at the  time and between
although the samples can be our
people charge lake for the team until
the dental report because the team  ipo may
have the samples but started
working with the sample is not 'la and
awaiting system release
so it can start processing the
kill last the actual processing time
does not start when the sample is aspirated
and the initial sample of de
processing of seeing it here at this
point of making it the digital ones respond
so we take you from there as point 1
points 2.3 and we evaluate all the points
in relation to the line compared
to five systems m 2000 that we have
there in data
well then the algorithm she the  Send yours
from the patient to the laboratory if
some type of analytical procedure is necessary,
such as centrifugation or by
text
by text, a vigorous option for batteries,
for example, liquid psychology,
but there yours are the easy ones,
if you want the routine course, the flow,
sorry.  of routine work with the
five of 2000
a month or so we made tubes with water
but the best system of identification
and  the taste of there for the cleanliness as if
the waters could pass the new
tests of the same time of all because of
course ours were here so they
could be ours it is done here
it would not be in real time and here it has been
done exactly in time  real to
have a real estimate of the
response time of one compared to the
other
the samples after we go back there
something that is approximate that is very
similar to what we have from miku has
so we analyze from there thousand 68
samples although we visit it
more diseases  sexually
transmitted with this percentage and there
in October in our
Justina laboratory and about 40 percent of the
intermed samples of this subject, so it is very
similar to be as close as possible
to the real situation
and well,
the processing time that they have
talked about in the  time 1 which is the
movement that the death aspire team
processes for him in 2000 we had
like 100 percent new
pr samples  Ocessed in less than two hours,
regardless of the type of test or
sample, then for all the
infection markers for which
we tested 100% at the time the
aspiration returned the results in
less than two or three
and how one compares and the time  two that
the time that one charges the equipment until
the result there the complete breath 95
% shows it in 52 15 and in 2005 2002
25% and 7 hours 30
but when one compares here yes
we also make an evolution it shows that
we urgently call where  the system is
free and allow access with torrico
there an urgent sample arrives it left
the line immediately no so
you have a soldier who marked it as an
urgent sample and there we do tests
with 20 samples
n it cleans
the multi samples that are processed in
up to  four hours
while in 2000 it
takes 30 hours to process the 20 samples
that we call these then for
patients in the current people that these
hours  s that is fooled do many many
different
last point that time 30 if the
arrival at the laboratory until
final report in the presentation and the
migration at the end here you can look
at the blue line and the red
and well this is 100% of  the
results reported in 2000 it took about
70 explosions three days to have the
total results the administration of
other samples does not happen that in the axis
only in nine hours
on average the average not
all the love that numerous
results arrived released reported and is not born
there were
rods compared to the 5 thousand 2000 that
took up to 74 hours to complete
all the liberal samples with those
recited in informed
and because they were bowls from among the
series and dth family samples that it
is very common for the prescriber the
doctor to ask  The two of them who both
cut th family and I see how important the
cytology is also because there the
cytology is waiting in the
HPV consultation to start  the
sentence reading also then water a
picture back from here back to all I
knew them also well here each
ball is a sample so as
we do everything with a sample we do not
do it to the ico to go through the point that they
have a return for the patient
So you have to wait until the end
of the meal routine, for example, to
start the amount of HPV here, so
that takes a long time and he says this whole
situation impresses me, simulation, but
what happened to Aldo's world,
then there are samples from here
that spoke  about 50-60 hours
for one of the towns that
started with hpv can be done, then the
family was seriously done, but there may be
time for the samples to be
processed and to make a new droplet
that can cover the samples of
another test  which then had been made
in the first place
and here they share it on the net
what happened to ross shows the same
coveted marco valli m who came out in
height much more  early that the
samples can go to real life
then we have 2000 forms
so there are three options two types of
tests per sample here it
takes an average of 30 hours to
see the second result obtained
in contrast in the barrel and they came out  in the
name of hours the two results as he
told you
then for us with a rumba the
workflow the
very important operational impact that comes due to the
speed rojitos after 32
hours they have a separate result here
nm 3000 it is like they dare to
Having the results that all of ours are
at a minimum of 62,000 and also in the
ready capacity is something important and
because in a laboratory that sees
many deaths many samples that if you
need as quickly as possible
air is the objects of the tournament
hospitals and there are many
urgent needs
and also in incomparable space
occupied by an exit compared to five
systems in this it is well also a
pers  one operator is only to quote
for one thousand 10,000 shares that for
five to limits you need two minimum
two or three people operators but
then area there is a reduced number of
people it is also clear for the
laboratory to have fewer people no and well
the most interesting feature  Maybe
it's random access because it
gives much more flexibility to the
laboratory in a
different way from the worker because you don't
work on more games Philosophy
Bach's idea is not to think while walking
and death we get to this lane and
there he continues working all the time  that you
need although in many requirements or
not in the team organizes the
trap flow to the truth
I have old wounds and they want to
allow a lot of flexibility in the laboratory
and write and interest the
work with the dead to any
movement
another point to do in efficiency from
the point  that it is possible to work with a
single tube for four by five,
that is to say, it is more the vph,
it is not necessary to know  rar by test
what happens is that the interest stress that
has 4 targets 4 agents but if the
prescription is only for family because of the
fence
but it will have the four results
but the three that these masquerades were not requested
are still in the system
for  14 days after the
reported result the doctor or patience
needs the result will also be able to
read it yaiza and it is not necessary to
check again a new website is necessary
sample because it is there to be according to
the sun in the form of a mask the mask is
thrown away  and there the
questioner informs it is also an
important important place for the
laboratory also so for
us and we are always there fighting
for science
the line represents a great
important efficiency and especially for tests
that have synergy like the tests that
are thought to be more low as  that of
implementing actions of presence and it
also enters them into consumption of genotypes
[Music]
individualized also then  You have
better and clear tests and it turns out to be very
reliable for all the
math marlin and that we present from the
calculations that came out very very possible and very
reliable I think that this is the last one
that you mail me says that you should contact
more darts also to have more
when  we have a lot more experience I
can direct but we start soon and
there thank you very much for listening and
thank you very much for the invitation also
great pleasure to try to speak for you
in Spanish thank you very
much thank you doctor levy for
your informative and very
interesting presentation well today we will start the
part live Q&A
if you guys have any questions
please click right now on the
box that says ha located on the far
left of the screen we will answer as
many of your questions and we don't have
time
our question our first
question to you on  doctor I saw you
from the point of view of the
pre-analytical processes what are the  s advantages
that you now are help and you have
I can and this is that the main thing is that
it is not necessary to be going by then from
the pure practical process you have to
endure wait until you have like
80 90 samples to start the bump of
in 2000 and  here not here there was one that
closes because it begins to process and media
also fear it is necessary to make the pothole
of your terra litic service this and
also another that stands out that is to
use a sample to be more than one
test as rest of the heras and test
but not speaking, you can also do
the same with hiv to participate so that it leaves
it is also not common for a person to
have to participate because of the risk
that the two justification side loads can be done
with the same
blood plasma sample so
those are the  two most important roosters of the
preanalytical magazine pus
thank you very much I think we have
time for one more question here one of
the essays discussed during your
presentation is the  multiplex test
for sexually transmitted
infections as you see the clinical
and operational utility of processing these four
markers at once
I think this is a test that we
loved that we really liked that it was
available in the next one because as a
brave family what  you are going to be
dumped in the laboratory after the
summer so it is very very common for the
writer to need dth family
or serious family for the time it is also very
common then to already have everything there and more
and more to request me as a plague
than as receiving in  The four
of us together are 7, it is more frequent in the world,
more because with a PH point, too,
so you have all the impossibility time you
can, but you make the door
of a table with only one sample and there you
can bear to report a result of two
or three or four.  so I think that
I am complete the gender health point of view
applying on a woman
because they have also been associated for
electric rooms i  s
and the first thing man also
perfect well thank you very much doctor
levy thank you very much for making this
presentation in Spanish considering that
our base language and to finish
we just wanted to know if you have any
final comments for our audience
well yes thanks to you and I think the
comment is  that we are going to be there
to accumulate experience as well and in a short
time given that we are there to be able to share
more data as
distance experience than available for
questions by mail
through water also
perfect good thanks again doctor
levy for your time and  for your important
research would you also
thank
us thank you we would also like to thank
water and our sponsor
water science affairs for underwriting
today's educational garden before we go
i would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions the  questions for which
we did not have time and present them  Questions
during the video on demand will be
answered via your
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
until August 2021 the light will notify you
by email when it is
available for playback we
encourage you to share  this
email with your colleagues who
couldn't attend today's live event
until next time and goodbye